I guess the Cliche is the modern, the
modern left, whatever people call it.
Like the,
you know,
capital l tribal left seems to be being
indoctrinated not by left wing policy
ideas. It's not about necessarily
socialism, it's about identity.
Arianism it's about policy based on
your immutable characteristics and how,
you know,
like going back to the green new deal,
like in the bill it talks
about racial equity,
what does that do to the environment?
But what does it mean? Um,
well equality would be like,
ew, ew. Equal opportunity to,
people are allowed to
try and if one succeeds,
congratulations, equity would be,
well let's determine whether or not you
are advantaged or privileged and then
hold you back or push you forward
based on these, these certain metrics.
I suppose it's, it's the problem I have
with it is that it's not quantifiable.
So this was actually something
that was really shocking to me.
I was sitting with my niece,
uh, and my, my sister,
my niece and my mom and I showed
this image that people like to share.
It's three people standing
up by a baseball of offense.
And there's a base is a baseball game
as a really short person who can't see.
There is a medium sized person who can
see a little bit and a very tall person
who just stands right up above the fence.
It says this is equality.
Each of them gets one crate,
one crate isn't enough for the short
guy and the two guys can already see.
I says this is equity and it shows
the short guy getting, you know,
three crates so they can all see now.
And I said,
the problem is when it comes to someone's
height, sure we can understand, let's,
let's, let's give the the crates to the
short guy so he can see along with us.
But how do you determine equity based on
the color of someone's skin or they're,
you know, like characteristics that
can't necessarily be quantified. Right?
So when Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez pushes
a bill forward that's purporting to be
about the environment,
but includes racial equity clauses,
are we to assume that her ideology
states that if you are not white,
you are poor by deaf?
Like it's a guarantee or do we have to
assume that each individual has different
advantages, different cards to play,
and some are born wealthy, some aren't.
And yes, there's historic
racism, but we can't make those
assumptions. Right? Right.
So this is, this is, to me,
one of the biggest problems I've been
having as like a lifelong left-leaning
individuals. Who do I vote for her? Right?
I was a big fan of Bernie
Sanders for awhile,
but then Bernie Sanders gets up
on stage at the debates and says,
white people don't know what it's like
to be poor. Well, that's hilarious.
W Go to fucking West Virginia
and visit the coal miners. Right?
And you know what's really weird?
I saw one of Bernie's tweets that I
looked at and I said, oh, come on man.
You know,
this is fucked up.
He was talking about how much more money
white men make than black women and
Latino men and all these different things.
And what he didn't include was Asian men.
Well, because Asian men make more money.
But here's what I think a lot of people
on the right miss. He said pay equity,
not pay equality.
Okay.
I think perhaps we should stop assuming
they don't know what they're saying
because a lot of people
assume what they're saying
is, you know, the, the gender,
the gender earnings gap is, is
real. But the gender pay gap,
it's um,
that if a man and a woman are
both offered the exact same job,
exact same experience in education,
women tend to get,
I think it's like three to 5% less. And
many people believe that's because they,
they're less likely to negotiate.
Just why you have like lean in,
tell women to be more, you know,
trying to be more assertive. Um,
but it's not this 77% number that's,
but there is an earnings gap, right?
The median salaries of men
and women are different.
So when Bernie says white men make x
more than these other demographics,
he said in his tweet,
pay equity, not equality.
He doesn't want fair pay for everyone
based on job. He's actually saying,
it doesn't matter what job you have,
everyone should be paid the same. Yeah,
that's nonsense. But then you see
what Cortez releases on our website.
If you're unwilling to work,
they'll provide economic security.
They actually mine, I believe
they took it off the site. Right?
But I think when they included in
the bill that they want equity,
not equality when they include on
their website. If you're unwilling,
they'll pay you.
And when Bernie says equity as well,
I think they're not talking about
equality. Like I don't think you know,
the average American understands what
they're actually saying is you should be
paid a flat rate period.
And when you're talking about the pay
gap being different from men and women,
we should clarify that.
What you're saying essentially is that
men choose different jobs and they work
more hours.
And that's the reason why they make that
much more money where it's 77 cents on
the dollar. Yeah. There. There was a,
an another study came out recently that
said that hours worked was almost the,
uh, 100% of the reason why men
and women earn different, uh,
at a median median salary. In some areas
a women actually earn more than men. Uh,
and there's I think seven cities.
I think this was on pew again, you,
you fact check me if you got
you, everybody thinks I'm
wrong or whatever. But uh,
I believe it was seven cities where
women out earn men by like seriously high
numbers,
like up to 20%.
So there's a lot of issues when it
comes to the pay gap and equality.
But without going on a tangent in that
area, I think what ends up happening is,
you know, I saw Bernie's tweet and I
responded to it by saying good news,
Bernie pay equality is enshrined in law.
And I signed it.
I cited three examples of where it's
illegal to discriminate based on gender.
And then someone pointed out to me, Tim,
he didn't say quality is said equity.
That would imply it doesn't
matter what job you have.
A petroleum engineer should earn the
same as a store clerk at h and m that's
equity that just because you
have an advantage because
if education doesn't mean
you should earn more than somebody else.
You see what I'm saying?
So the fact that there's people
that actually believe that,
that don't believe that
w w w first of all,
that's going to absolutely discourage
people from trying to succeed.
Why would you,
if you could get the same amount as the
CEO of Exxon as you can working at 21
forever, forever 21 or whatever,
Abercrombie and Fitch, why would you,
why would you try hard? Why would
you exceed? Why would you succeed?
Why would you excel?
I think it's fair to point out some
people would you know what if there's no,
if there's no real,
I mean other than social status,
if there's no reveal real consequences.
I think social status might be one
of the prime driving factors of,
of most people. I don't
know, man. Not Enough.
Not enough to really encourage innovation
and progress. I can agree with that.
For sure.
But I also think there's a,
there was a saying that I was told a lot
that people don't get rich because they
want money,
they get rich because they're passionate
about something and the money comes
after, you know, they always say that the
money comes after something like that.
And I'd point out every,
every day I take no days off.
It's been a couple of years
with me not taking any days off.
I work literally every day full time.
Right now I'm producing six
youtube videos every day.
Only one of them is a real seven
days a week, seven days a week,
nonstop for two years straight. Fuck you
doing it yourself. I like it. It's fun.
And that's a thing. I'm
not, I'm not doing it.
You're enjoying this old lady down
the tunnel. I do it because, you know,
I see things on, uh, so for the most
part on, on my main youtube channel,
I do one video every day at 4:00 PM,
which tends to be just like a news
analysis piece. But I'm not perfect.
Sometimes I, you know, get
all hyperbolic and stuff.
My second channel is me
just ranting and you know,
not really swearing but still
just like heavy opinion stuff.
I do it because it's fun. You know, I
see something, I want to explore it. Uh,
I used to travel all the time.
You know, when I worked at vice,
I was in all these different countries
and all these dangerous places.
Not because I wanted to
have a name for myself,
not because I wanted to make money,
I wanted to watch a revolution.
I want to know why it was happening and
I want to talk to the people who are
experiencing it. So I can, I can,
I can relate to people who say
money isn't a motivator for sure.
But I've also talked to
people in Scandinavia who
have told me they sort of give
up at a certain point because I
can't remember which country it was.
It may have been Sweden or uh,
or Norway.
But these two women told me that
after like $77,000 per year,
they tax like 80% of your income.
So people just stop.
They literally just stopped.
That's another proposition, right?
This is something else that's
been discussed in terms
of anyone who makes more
than x amount per year,
taxing them over 70% I agree with
the progressive tax wholeheartedly.
I disagree with a number that high.
What do you think it should be? I don't,
I don't know. But I will say we
need more progressive brackets.
We need to keep going. And
you know, I gotta say maybe,
maybe at $10 million 70% does make sense.
But I kind of leaned towards not really,
cause it seems like man,
that's a lot of money. That's a lot.
That's, that's, that's more, that's,
that's ridiculous amount.
You know,
I think Steve Bannon said something
like a five in front of it or something.
But I don't know.
I'm not an economist,
but I do believe a progressive
tax makes the most sense.
And I can explain it to you if you want
to hear it. Sure. So there was a study,
I believe it was from Harvard,
you need $77,000 per year,
as may have been 10 years ago,
in order to be middleclass
median in the United States.
That means if you make 77,000 you'll
have a vacation, you'll have insurance,
you'll have a car, you can raise a
family, you can send them to school,
all that stuff, but you have
nothing left over for savings.
You have nothing left over for
investments. If you make $100,000 a year,
you're gonna have $23,000 leftover for
investing. Eventually. At a certain point,
if you only need $77,000 if
you're making 10 million,
you've got 9,000,900 900,000 that you
can invest and just be independently
wealthy and be rich forever. Now, I have
no problem with being wealthy. I have no,
I have no problem with other people
being wealthy and living off of their
investments and all that. But there is a
point where you have to realize the, the,
the coalescing of power,
the monopolizing of power is a really
dangerous thing for any society to few
individuals holding too much
power can destabilize an economy,
can destabilize a country.
The problem with communism,
you snap your fingers and you put
a centralized authority in place.
At least that's how it's
been every single time.
And then they hold all the
cards and they can oppress over,
they want the problem with laissez faire.
Capitalism has over time,
which is why it's better
in a lot of ways over time.
It eventually becomes a
centralized oligopoly of a
few corporations controlling
everything,
which we're kind of seeing now.
So all the progressive tax can
really do is slow that process down,
which I think is a good
thing. But ultimately I think
just looking at the system,
eventually you end up
kind of where we are,
where six media companies control
everything. And then, you know,
some companies are the biggest funders
of certain politicians and corporations
is to have too much power. I
mean, there, there is, uh, I,
I remember reading a report or a story
about how wealthy people have like three
or four times more ability to influence
a politician than like the majority of
the people in the country simply
because paying for expensive dinners and
lobbying earns you favors, you
know, super pacs paying, you know,
guaranteeing funding for, for a politician
earns your favors. So it's, you know,
look, if a million people
tell me they want you know, x,
but the people who are paying me like pa
funding my campaign are paying me more.
Well,
who am I going to provide favors too?
And then once I'm done with my campaign
run, I can go to job at their company.
Yet these are problems.
So without going on too big of a rant,
I think ultimately a progressive tax can
help slow the process down of special
interests, acquiring too much
power. Eventually it happens anyway.
But with a flat tax,
you're basically saying at a certain
point you can just keep dumping more and
more money into different investments,
making more and more money and increasing
your power exponentially and other
people can't catch up to you and
then power becomes too quick. Right?
Yeah.
I think in this country we tried to look
at success and achievement is something
that everyone's striving for and we don't
want to put any restrictions on that.
Yeah,
we look at capitalism is the reason why
everything's going so great over here.
This is America. Atlanta, the free home
of the brave go out there and kick ass.
We're not going to saddle
you now with debt. Um,
but it makes sense that after
a while as we're seeing today,
but I don't mean what is,
what's the best way to do it?
I mean is not going to work.
What does work?
I think a mixed economy, well mixed
economy where we are right now, right?
A portion of income is paid in taxes from
government programs for the, for the,
um,
for defense and things like that.
I just think we have a big problem with
corruption. I think we've got bloat.
I think we've got government agencies
that instead of reforming and breaking
them down, we just slept
more bandaids on top. Yeah,
we've got a festering wound and we're
putting bandages over bandages. You know,
it's like a certain
point you got to Redo it.
We also have systems that
are in place that, I mean,
in terms of like the way communities have
always existed in certain communities,
there's just poverty and crime and no
one does anything to fix it. Right.
And it seems to be that we'll,
we're more than willing to go to other
countries and nation built were more than
willing to pump money
into different countries,
especially if they have natural resources.
But in our own country, we're not,
I mean,
the,
the greatest resources of course human
beings and the best way to make America
great or stronger would be
to have less losers. Well,
what's the best way to have less losers?
To have more people succeed?
What's the best way to
have more people succeed?
Give them more opportunity and
chance to not be stuck in a quagmire,
not be trapped in a ghetto.
This is, yeah. So, uh,
I believe we should allocate access
from other areas to improve the certain
areas. In that sense, I believe
in socialism to a certain extent.
Like I will leave in it with,
with fire departments.
I believe in it with
the police department.
I believe we should spend money
that comes out of, you know,
the public pool to fix things.
Right. I look at New York,
there are some neighborhoods
that are really bad,
some neighborhoods that are really good.
Well,
if we take access from the really great
neighborhoods and use that to fix roads,
pay for schools in poor neighborhoods,
crime is one of the biggest
correlations for crimes. Poverty. Yes.
So if we can get better schools, we need
to reform the school system straight up.
If we can get better hospitals,
if you can fix the roads,
then we're doing a lot to reduce
crime and we're just poverty.
And a rising tide lifts all ships.
Yes. So that's why, you know, I,
that's why I like Bernie Sanders,
although I will, I say I make sure,
I tell people like, he has a little
too left for me. He is, but when we're,
when we're looking at who we had in
2016 I was like, yeah, Bernie's my guy.